[Music]
after that crazy genv finale after that
awesome Loki episode 5 after the
Invincible season 2 premiere we finally
are getting the thing we've all been
waiting for the echo Spider-Man
4 Echo that's what we're waiting for
echo echo I'm joined by Echo right now
we're letting John sleep get a lot of
shade for this already for some reason
and we can take guess's as to why but
you know what I'm going in with an open
mind or you I am I'm a big David Mac fan
he co-invented Ekko so I'm excited to
see what this is this is tvma oo yeah
man isn't that awesome that's exciting I
didn't know that changes kind of the
mind frame around some stuff we've heard
ladies and gentlemen leave a like like
like like like like let's see what this
looks
like
[Music]
Maya Kingpin right away the first line I
think is Kingpin I see everything that
you
are always have full
Kingpin nice it's gritty
Kingpin all right tvma
Kingpin
blood in the white
suit oh my God this actually feels
violent don't be
[Music]
afraid this feels like the Kingpin we
know yeah this is not like Hawkeye at
all so far that jump a
little loving the sound design so
far you have so much pain in you you you
e so much rage rage rage that you can't
contain
it yo this trailer is working for yeah
this is a great trailer and the guy from
H Hawkeye
right punished
oh yeah there's actual violets here yeah
they shot the guy in the head oh my
God
a little Daredevil T is that Daredevil
yeah you and
I are the
same oh the connection between her and
Kingpin
so who's the
monster I thought that was a
great is that what say your profile to
tvma to stream there's like a setting to
get to Echo uh whoa holy crap wow I you
know there's been a lot of morbid
cynical thoughts surrounding this show
you know what this made me think of
there's been so many people who have
been really making
www. reject Nation shop Thrive this year
my God guys thank you so much we got
shirts like citizen gang over there the
one Koy is rocking right now the real
regets tickets we also got Child
Protection Services we got space babies
of the Galaxy we got who watches the
influencers or who influences the
influencers I mean it's Watchman
inspired that's where I got confused we
got Last of Us inspired teas we got
Ahsoka inspired te's we got Loki teas it
has been a successful year and it's
personally my favorite way to support
the channel so thank you guys so much
for going out of your way and checking
out that shop coyi uh yeah man I just
got to say that I thought that I like
the character-driven narrative here
between her caught and sort of this
darker phase in her life and watching
how her development and excuse me guys
it was just non-stop editing all day
yesterday so I'm getting my brain
working right now yeah watching the
development between her and Kingpin
seeing sort of the crossroads she's at
between being a hero and succumbing to
the darkness but you're watching how she
became like kingp like doing it through
visual physical representation of it
yeah my favorite part about it
especially with Kingpin was I was one of
those people who was like I wasn't a big
fan of the way he was portrayed in
Hawkeye and this feels more akin to how
Vincent deno's portrayal was in the
Daredevil show I really enjoyed all the
the I think it's Chu CH choka
inspiration of the Indian Nation I like
seeing a the vibe it's probably the
people we've seen the least on screen
like like Native Americans are probably
the people we've had the least groups of
represented in a in a big property so
I'm like excited to see cuz that like
violence looked hardcore the culture
that I don't know a lot about like I'm
I'm Cherokee somewhere down the line
it's cool to be like learn that like we
had with this Marvel like I got to learn
more about Muslim culture through the
comic and then even more through the
show it'd be cool if they get to touch
on that through this show it's because
they're trying to get in with Martin
scorsi who just play the long they did K
of the flower Moon which is a different
when they agre with that they went
through like what characters do we have
that are Native American let's get
Scorsese to direct secret War
yes I was pleasantly surprised by this
trailer man I thought it would just be
like a cheese fest I was afraid this
trailer would be the things I didn't
like about Hawkeye which tended to be
really really rough editing a Cheesy is
tone kind of undermining the more
serious elements of the characters I
love like I I really love Hawkeye and
when they let him be a family man that
worked I really loved Kate Bishop when
they let her like lean into that like um
fighter but also like being young that
worked but when they undermine both of
them and especially like we both had
Kingpin problems it really didn't work
so I wasn't all that excited for Ekko
not because of Ekko but because of
Hawkeye so the fact that they're kind of
making this shaped more like the Kingpin
show is interesting because clearly
that's the draw versus like character
like Eko which isn't known as well but
that's kind of how you get characters
that aren't known as well in that that's
kind of how Comics work here's a
character you know and love here's a
guest starring role obviously the show
is called echko but I thought it was
smart to have the lead of the trailer
not the lead of the show pull you in by
having Kingpin as like your your eyeline
right so you get your familiarity and
it's more the familiarity of Daredevil's
tone and then you also get the surprise
for us of the violence the white suit
with the blood splatter the insane stunt
work that one shot of Daredevil I was
afraid this would be okay let's like
catch up on Ekko maybe a lot of
flashbacks when I saw two minutes I was
like it's going to be like a minute of
Hawkeye and then maybe like they'd
sprinkle in a Cambio and then at opening
with Kingpin at first I was like oh this
kind of like it's not the Echo Show it's
the Kingpin show but then I was like
wait they're connecting these two people
through this narrative through this
violence through this situation and then
the audience is going wait I am
interested because I am familiar with
these characters so I thought it really
worked yeah well a big part of it is
that it it just doesn't feel like they
were utilizing Kingpin to get some guest
St cameo in there it's about the
relationship between them he's the coad
from the story not just the the way they
utilize exactly like it's about the
influence of the relationship that she
had with him and also the
dichotomy of the situation because it is
her
father in a sense right like we had I
forget some of the details in the
specific of show with her actual father
but this is her father figure still
someone who raised her you also got the
complexity like yeah he she shot him and
even though he lost his eye he still
doesn't want her dead like he seems like
he still really cares very much for her
in that one scene and the other part
about it too that I I loved is I was not
interested in an Echo Show we've both
been like well that's out this year but
this made her seem like a very
compelling character in a way that made
me go yeah I I'd be down to actually see
this character the the things that that
have me concerned are all the behind the
scenes stuff that right right the fact
they're putting it out one day but you
know that could be just like viewer
reception not of necessarily the show
but of people like us going like do we
want this it could be reactionary to not
the content but to the feedback from
Hawkeye you know what I mean yeah yeah
this is maybe how you get people to
watch it by having a Kingpin uh focal
point having Daredevil Cameo having but
if you do it in the day you're going to
have people talking about all those
things maybe that's the idea I love the
framing of a lot of this a lot of these
uh flashback shots what's funny about it
is it kind of has the cinematography of
the Daredevil movie it's like they
flashed back to Daredevil the movie not
the show it look it doesn't it look kind
of look like the like 2000 like Marvel
Fox Vibes like there's definitely I was
like all right so is the Daredevil great
in this Charlie Cox or Ben thank God
youit felt when they showed the inside I
don't know what it was but something
about the inside of the car poov I was
just like new medals C it was it's the
cinematography of it that really feels I
think it's Mark stepen Johnson it
definitely feels like like that but I
think there's a lot of really cool
symmetry in these shots a lot of cool
framing I don't know if the sound design
is just due to like I feel like they'll
probably do some of the cool sound
design with going in and out of ekko's
perspective because she is uh because
she is deaf so you would and they did
that in the Hawkeye show too right yeah
I think they showed more violence in
this trailer than it did in moonnight
yeah yeah and I mean it being tvma is
pretty neat and maybe that's one of the
reasons they decided to dump all the
episodes at once that it just seems like
such it's just such a weird I also it's
what the last cheek show like I think
Iger came in and so cap 4 is like half
cheek half Iger era if I'm remembering
correctly I think this is the last full
chiic maybe they're just like let's end
this era in 202
2024 clean I think it's a weird ass time
jary they I think it's a weird ass time
to release this trailer because of what
it's being sandwiched in between yeah I
thought this was like December for some
reason but it's January so they didn't
need to rush it I'd be I I I'd be lying
if you know I I gotta say like I thought
this was a better trailer than both
Marvel's trailers yeah yeah and it
showed more of what the I haven't seen
the Marvels this felt like I know more
of what it's about whereas the Marvel
trailers are just like there's stuff
happening and they got Beasty Boys it's
a solid trailer and I think like just
with their Disney plus experience maybe
the first episode will be like good and
then I I'm just kind of hoping it
doesn't dip halfway the P ultimate
episode will be not story driven but
it'll have stuff happen and maybe
they'll punch at the end yeah I just
hope it doesn't Meander something like
that that's the one thing even Visual
and tonal wise I could see it happening
where it's a it's like really there's
like gravitas it's really serious it
looks cool but then maybe it becomes a
little perfunctory and
and stuff they're like all right well
they're walking into that building there
they go I could see I could see a bad
version of this but for a first trailer
I got to say it really won me over a lot
I'm shocked this is maybe the biggest
surprise trailer of recent memory
definitely yeah I was very cynical about
it that's honest that's honest I did not
want to wake up to do this after working
so late but this looks the most
different of uh expectation to reality
but also from um what we got the last
time we saw a character to the new a th%
man all righty guys what did you think
about this Echo trailer were you as
pleasantly surprised by this as we were
um people are probably mad at us for
even liking the trailer confirming that
we're watching it even acknowledging
that we are here Greg I'm sure there are
people who are also mad because we came
in a bit cynical and then we liked it
and they're like why were you negative
and before the people that commented 10
seconds in are like why are you negative
people that waited to the end are like
why are you shills and now the sence I'm
going to say it's going to piss off a
lot of people that are fans of this
remind me of The
Equalizer you know I mean totally like a
ponderous violence and like what
violence does to a person in stuff yeah
and then really using like your your
Keen sense of awareness and using the
like environment around you for like the
tone of yeah they gave me equalizes so
yeah deal with that comment board sorry
for talking so
much what are you talking all right
talking to Loki fans let me get this up
and I got to try to take a nap and I
forgot to mention we're going to be
doing a a live stream tomorrow for those
who care who made it this far hey you're
still watching Invincible Loki news all
the stuff tomorrow live be here see you
[Music]
guys